un nouveau logo pour symboliser l'union
de la bourgogne et de la franche comté
mais force est de constater que cette
nouvelle identité visuelle divise plutôt
un peu tout le monde aurait pu trouver
ça que c'est pas ouf comme logo pour 18
minéraux non il est simple c'est soft
mais bon comprend le message donc mind
chaque pale mon avis c'est pas vendeur
je me sens pas vendeur c'est un peu
l'eau j'aime bien la couleur il y en a
pas assez je n'ai pas parlant pas du
tout pas d'image pas de
ebook de renaître à l'origine de cette
création lagence bisontine d'artagnan
qui a su avoir privilégié les cris à
l'image dans l'alliance du noir et du
jour permet d'associer la lisibilité et
la clarté et l'accent a été mis sur le e
de région et de compter et donc cette
assise en colonne vertébrale légèrement
décentré crée aussi le mouvement 18000
euros le logo trop cher pour certains
pour une grande région qui compte deux
millions huit cent vingt mille habitants
cela revient à
0,00 6 euros par personne c'est un coût
qui correspond au prix du marché je
dirais qu'on est plutôt dans la
fourchette basse des prix du marché pour
ce type de création pour un logo ce sont
les élus qui les premiers ont dégainé
leurs tweets ainsi sophie montel du
front national écrit tout ça pour ça
impressionnant vraiment ou encore
christophe perny ex ps désormais ralliés
à emmanuel macron qui fait le parallèle
avec le logo du jura département qu'il a
présidé en côte d'or le président du
conseil départemental ne décolère pas
non plus j'ai découvert le lego le
nouveau logo de la région comme leader
de l'opposition en allant consulter le
site de la région tout ça s'est fait
complètement catimini je sais pas par
qui j'ai même pas quelle agence été
recrutés pour faire ça mais quand on
voit le résultat c'est consternant pour
permettre aux bourguignons et au franc
comtois de participer à leur nouveau
logo commun françois sauvadet propose
dans une pétition en ligne de lancer un
concours graphique destinée aux lycéens
des internautes honteux déjà posté leurs
suggestions